das ist irgendwie was was eben keine
sagte selbstversorgung das ist verdammt
hart ist wollen wir so hilflos bis die
hat sich als zwei stunden nicht nur den
kopf gehoben
als ich vorhin zu den ziegen gekommen
bin habe ich mit ihnen die hier unter
dieser golf ecke liegt dieser wärme
vorgefunden die lag kopfüber im schlamm
ganz komische körperhaltung ich dachte
sie wäre tot
er hat sehr war ganz schwach den kopf
gehoben und die augen aufgemacht also
das ist jetzt vielleicht 45 stunden her
und ich habe sie ins warme gebracht hier
in die decke eingewickelt ihr wahres
wasser gebracht ihr zuhören sirup
gebracht den geben wir allen siegen
immer nach der geburt wenn sie ein
bisschen kraftlos sind kein tierarzt
können kommen ist es samstagnachmittag
mittlerweile und irgendwie fühlt sich
nicht als zuständig es ist immer so wenn
irgendetwas passiert dann am wochenende
und dann ist kein tierarzt bereit
irgendwas zu tun und ich habe keine
ahnung was los ist sie hat keine
offensichtlichen verletzungen ich finde
dass ein bein ein bisschen seltsam
aussieht
ich habe hier im stall mal wieder steine
gefunden das heißt es war noch wieder
leute hier
ob das was damit zu tun hat keine ahnung
wie wird ihr so gerne helfen aber ich
weiß über das ist nichts sie ist einfach
nur komplett schwach sie ist recht
letzte sie alles ja schon die einzige
auf der weide getötet worden das war
auch die einzigen die wir legen konnten
und davor dass ihr erhalte die mächtige
gebärmutterkrebs denn das alte geburt
der kleinen gestorben
liebe und hass und menschenbezogen
manchmal habe ich angst dass ich hier
auf dem kanal irgendwie ein romantisches
bild von selbstversorgung zeichen ist ja
sehr ist jedes ist nur was man so an
aufnahmen machen kann ich meine die
tiere und wollen die schönen der garten
des wunderschönen und es macht natürlich
super viel spaß aber ich hoffe dass ich
euch auch rüberbringen
es ist verdammt hart ist wie ziehen
gerade
so wir haben die letzten drei tage
eigentlich nichts anderes gemacht hätte
kisten zu schleppen und auszupacken und
natürlich muss genau dann sowas
passieren und ist nicht der einzige tag
an dem er so ist wie heute es gibt immer
wieder solche sachen wo es einfach so
heftig und krasses und ich versuche das
auch mit euch zu teilen in der hoffnung
dass ihr ein realistischeres bild davon
haben was es bedeutet wenn man seine
eigenen tiere hält es wäre so einfach in
den laden zu gehen und mir da mein
fleisch zu kaufen und meine milch zu
käse und meine eier und ich hatte null
verantwortung für irgendein tier ich
könnte in urlaub fahren was auch immer
ich in urlaub fahren möchte ich würde
keine einzige träne vergießen wenn es
einem der tiere schlecht geht von ihnen
meine lebensmittel stammen weil ich es
nicht mal mitbekommen würde aber ich
finde es einfach viel ehrlicher als
selbst zu machen
ich sehe mich zum ersten mal eine kamera
gerade ich sicher dass ich vielleicht
haben wir müssen das ist irgendwie was
was eben keine sagte der
selbstversorgung
das ist verdammt hart ist man wie so
hilflos bis die halbwelt sich als zwei
stunden nicht über den kopf gehoben
die blind sind noch nicht macht dieses
knospen sind übrigens die anderen sieben
gefressen
jetzt kurz nach hause und dann machen
auch mal so ein terror bei allen die als
einem umkreis von 50 kilometern sich
vielleicht irgendwie ihn dazu bewegt
bekomme hier her zu kommen oder das für
die ziege vorbei trinken können der plan
war jetzt nicht geht wenn ich
wiederkommen
unser tierärztlicher notdienst ist heute
nicht für sie bereit
wir bitten sie zu unseren regulären
sprechzeiten von motor kommt 10 uhr bis
13 uhr blablabla bei uns anzurufen
nächster versuch
[Musik]
nicht so weiter nach meinen blöden
ziegen buch und versuche herauszufinden
was sie hat und dann gehe ich wieder hin
und auch risiken
[Musik]
knox gefunden aber ich habe auch die
außer tage gefunden die ich gerne
verlosen möchte es haben ja drei leute
gewonnen beim adventskalender video 1
habe ich schon verschickt ein gewinner
päckchen aber für die anderen habe ich
die sachen nicht mehr gefunden weil wir
gerade umziehen
und jetzt kann ich das zweite auch
losschicken einmal nämlich angelika
vierkant gewonnen einmal angelika
schindler also irgendwie 2 angelika
zufällig und dann noch rezept schachtel
aber rezept schachtel hat sich
zurückgemeldet
ich weiß dass du einige von meinen
videos schaust also vielleicht ja auch
dieses und wenn ja dann schreibt uns
bitte deine emailadresse weil wir wollen
dir gerne deinen gewinn zu schicken und
ich bin total happy dass ich das grab
gefunden habe weil das buch ist so gut
wie kann man nämlich nach symptomen
sortiert aus finden was sein ziel
gefehlt
also normalerweise eine goldgrube aber
gerade wenn er meint dass ein symptom
was sie zeigt dass schwäche und das kann
alles und nichts bedeuten
[Musik]
ich gebe jetzt noch mal ein bisschen
zucker im museum laufen das ist sie ein
bisschen aufgeregt
das heißt du vorhin bassstimme gemacht
ja das weibchen hey da die armee aber
sie lebt noch ich war halt sicher dass
sie gut ist wenn ich ja komme ich hatte
schon die schule geholt damit ich sie
damit abtransportieren kann
es ist jetzt 21 uhr und ich habe
tatsächlich noch eine tierarzt zum
aufgetrieben die jetzt noch vorbei kommt
und sich lupinen anschaut
also mache ich mich jetzt gleich noch
mal auf den weg und dann schauen wir mal
was dabei rauskommt
[Musik]
schaut mal wer bei uns zu hause ist zwar
viel zu kalt draußen und wir wissen was
sie hat sie hat listerien normalerweise
kann man das auch ganz gut behandeln
wenn man es früh erkennt aber sie ist
halt jetzt schon super schwachen
deswegen haben wir sie jetzt nach hause
geholt die tierärztin bereich der hammer
sie hat ihn mit mir in ihren tierarzt
wagen geladen hat hier bis nach hause
getragen ja jetzt ist noch wichtig ist
sie nicht umkippt also ich hab ihn noch
in kisten hinten rein gesteckt damit sie
ein bisschen aufrecht bleibt sie hat
antibiotika bekommen gegen die mysterien
wir haben gestern noch bis 2 uhr haben
sie schon für die ziele gemacht und sie
hatte trotzdem nur noch 33,3 grad
körpertemperatur
wo liegen eigentlich 38 40 haben sollten
und sie wiegt jetzt hier und ich habe
total fest da rein zu gehen und zu
gucken wie sie geht ist der nächste
morgen aber machen das jetzt
das ist immer ein ganz schlechtes
zeichen in der pause so aufbläht sie hat
es leider nicht geschafft ist die beste
die ich hier hatte
[Musik]
könnt ihr mir helfen sie herauszubringen
das findet das video aber also ist es
mal nicht mal ihr können sie noch nicht
mal beerdigen wie man essen kann will
sie jetzt auch nicht mehr wenn das
fleisch eigentlich noch gut ist weil sie
ist noch vorhanden aber sie hat so viel
antibiotika und medikamente bekommen
erst dann abend und beerdigen kann man
sonst hier auch nicht also das wird
einfach vom abdecke abholt ganz
unromantisch in dieses riesen müllauto
eingetippte und dann ist sie wenn ihr
lust habt ein video zu schauen wo ich
aus münchens milch käse herstellen und
sie merke und wo es ihnen auch richtig
gut geht dann schaut gerne mal da drüben
vorbei ansonsten sehen wir am samstag
wieder für ein neues video